bringing this up is because I think not
only off of an LCQ win but doing his
absolute best versus the evolution
champion himself right here could easily
be like okay
I'm nice again I'm nice heading into
Game one of you Toto versus eggs those
very own party wolves
let's get it going yeah coming in on
that key lick versus a bald oh here it
is
yeah bring out on this stage is I mean
it's obviously pretty apparent right
here we go a little bit of poke damage
out there no one's renting to too risky
just yet
oh good for there and he just gets the
punish off it with the two ways he's in
the mansion stance so you've got to see
what makes up what they need yeah
disrespect get me out of there I don't
want to deal with this right it's the
low so a lot of in you toes match off
versus skill we just couldn't see a
mountain offense and right now he's just
all
oh right there but okay nice block on
the stance mix-up and that's kind of
been like the claim to fame at all good
signs different there from party wolf
it's not a lethal hit but hey we'll take
that one
ten o'clock meters assault Chargers have
no time to be stopped just yet five
seconds left
twenty more for a smart leaders backing
off you got a little bit of damage right
there there could be possibly a soul
charge right now but he gets the lethal
head and this was not gonna be out of
time you totals gonna lose the first
round so we define the clock let's go to
get round boy I guess he just was not
willing to use the sole charge on that
one maybe trying to save it for this
round whatever the case may be right now
party wolf has a strong offensive
momentum coming into it add a life
essence never say he's flying to give as
much card damage on it as possible since
you know in the yellow trying to move
him down okay
trying to mix them up with the fake
unblockable right there maybe try to
catch them stepping or anything like
that but 20 votes did not fight it's
gonna get hip on the mid there okay
another one all but there's the stun
okay see time here we go here we go oh
we caught him ookay me in there it is
got the low weight up on you toto
he's gonna run up up this [ __ ] just
like this okay then here we go you
juggle like two meters to burn here
though lots of potential also flashing
guard deepest part you'll look up pretty
promising for you total right now just
be quite a bit of health yeah I think
taking er right around right now with me
super super good for mental stamina and
overall morale free mistletoe because
they lost you strain one of them was
that unfortunate timeout but he's got
the sidestep right there and he's
playing beautifully right now playing
around what party wolf finally getting a
hit right there
chart comes out really wants to make
something happen right now but dives
into the DM scrapes on the toe just like
that each other now in the fourth toe
pics cost a lot more than that red
flashing guard gave right now for part
of ocean says get launched that he's
gonna have to do it this set up and that
guard gauge could be prevalent so that's
why he goes to the gi- yep and that's
the point where he can punish the two a
is just what do you know that red
flashing garbage is apparent I think you
Toto training onto guard break them so
you can win ground and have them have a
replacement or you'd go into the next
one if at all possible probably do it
yeah so that actually completely turning
the tides right now you know having to
fart red flashing guard yet sure pretty
wolf has his own o2 bars or it's on
Texas deal with but now preying upon
that guard break it's gonna get good
damage here into the lethal heads okay
the set up is prevalent Oliver at the
ledge okay just backs off doesn't want
to deal with the salt are probably
I'm scary to move forward right here
trying to respect each other but party
will don't me two meters to you there we
go soldier yeah I mean it's not like you
doesn't have another bar right so he he
can make something happen with one more
bar
oh right Baird sitting hit below and
this is mix up City champ he goes
through the rolls to be able to get out
of the situation and now he's pressing
advantage he's backed her you gotta
watch that see there's the timer but I
party was in the lead damage wise and
now he solidified that he's in the lead
there might be a full charge this to
drain the life of all but he got him in
the start he's actually he's gonna run
out the clock with it gorgeous you know
killed there you go party up securing
that taken game of one over you Toto
that wine is done right there I am so
surprised at your photos on willingness
to use his bar to stop the clock it's
it's it's honestly kind of astounding
you know what why play with my food
finish your plate okay you got leftovers
on there we don't we can't let them go
to tomorrow finish it now okay and
that's why one of the reasons why
Keeling was so strong right is because
not only do they have that other
bar-b-que a little bit of extra house to
play with so that he could get he could
decide that he wants to press buttons
safely there and get that car ahead that
got him the game
are nothing cute for a stack that tank
over the back we go label hit on the
6-inch beam okay yeah but note I see
does Texas throw here so uh party wolf
is trying to step to be able to put him
closer and closer to the wall so he
himself is not actually at the wall but
here's the man at stance I'm there the
check he's really trying to do it all
got the loophole that's the difference
yeah
easy money baby I mean I'm sure he's
fine okay got the low right there and
you told I was having trouble getting up
right now he's really thinking about
putting offensive pressure negative to
on
yeah I think he was cute maybe
remembering how skilled spots the
negative to on him and so he tried to
block right there plus frames here we go
a little bit of BB active then he's up
the wall so he's probably really scared
there the GI that's guaranteed and
that's gonna kill it set point in fact
you told us facing uh we're going home
just straight up right now I mean he's
naked though so uh so you get the power
up on that one the setup is coming in
yeah okay got the macron but now here's
the true mix-up he's close to the wall
and yeah he doesn't want to press too
hard
it's really adding up Lauren I mean if
you didn't need to use it that round but
I wonder if he's going to be using in
the next one coming up here
you took that route with emphatic
pressure though he was able to out poke
and mix this man but party will holding
his scarred is the GI they're into
lethal hits big
no it's currency you got a deal with it
nice jump over from party boat is laying
on the pressure do it the pony will see
it's gonna eliminate the evolution
champion Ponyville taking it to O over
you toto
just like that kidding us they Adam
beautiful job by party won't so
excellent equitably total as well time
and time again we see him at all these
tournaments but getting those dummies
been normally winning each of those
events winning evolution as well but
this time this is party will rain after
just winning LCQ he comes up a wins
against the former Evo champion the Evo
champion of this year yeah and now we're
seeing him make the run through losers
my god what a story to be told like man
who ran the